so I'm going to start with a question
Eric
um so if I told you that I am aiming to
maximize muscle growth for overall for a
particular muscle group doesn't really
matter but I'm aiming to maximize muscle
growth over the next six months and I'm
presenting you with a binary choice I am
either going to do sets of about 10 Reps
for the muscle group I'm training or
about 25 30 reps which one would you
advise me to do from from an
evidence-based perspective
uh I'm thinking of a very specific page
in the old manual studying for the cscs
exam and they had the beautiful little
infographic you know where it was like
this is the strength range and this is
hypertrophy and this is muscular
endurance everybody went with that
forever and then all the studies came up
came out with the really high high rep
low load training and everybody said
throw that away so the the two options
you gave me I would say both totally the
same no need to sweat over the details
so that is I think a very justifiable
answer to give and I also think that
it's the wrong answer and it's the
answer I scripted for you so uh if
people are listening don't be like ah
Eric's a dumbass and Greg and Eric are
about to fight uh no we we call this a a
learning opportunity apparently there's
research on this if instead of just
giving someone the right answer if you
ask someone a question and they give the
wrong answer and then you can Leverage
The Shame well not leverage the shame
but in a uh
in a thoughtful way explain why they're
wrong in a non-judgmental way apparently
uh people remember better
um I I got that from the YouTube channel
veritasium so hopefully Derek wasn't
bullshitting with that one uh but anyway
so that's that's what we're going for
here anyway so the answer you gave uh
you know 10 reps 30 reps per set seems
to be the same so for me as an
individual trying to gain as much muscle
as possible no difference doesn't matter
uh either one's fine
so that is an answer that that comports
well with the research where you know
you take two groups of people put
one-on-one program one on another
program run it for three months four
months whatever check gains over time uh
but that may not necessarily be true for
individuals and I think that that's a
point that people intuitively understand
really well in other contexts but maybe
don't understand quite as well
intuitively when it comes to resistance
training research so here's an example
so let's say someone runs a study on
basketball players in the off season
where you take uh you know you you
randomly allocate groups you take one
group of people and say hey this off
season all we're doing is resistance
training and we're going to try to get
you as strong and powerful as possible
the other group you say you know hey you
gotta like you can't get too exhausted
by the end of the game like we we still
want to be firing on all cylinders in
the fourth quarter when the other team
is fading we want to be able to leave
our starters in the game longer Etc so
the entire off-season we're just going
to do conditioning work to try to get
you in as good of shape as possible
if you run that study
and the results are that for the
subsequent season there's no difference
between the two protocols like the
effects on you know box scores are the
same like points rebounds assists
whatever the the effect on Advanced
stats is the same you know you could
compare those group means and say hey
these were two similarly efficacious
interventions however I think people who
know anything about basketball wouldn't
therefore assume these two things work
the same on average therefore they'll
work the same for all individuals so you
know if you have a young Bean pole
coming into the league like Chet
Holmgren uh you know it's it's pretty
obvious that he does need to spend time
in the weight room and bulk up so he
doesn't get bullied on the post so you
know for that individual I think someone
could could look at that and be like
well you know maybe these two
interventions are similarly efficacious
on average but for this person like he
definitely needs to be in the weight
room and for some one else who you know
maybe is already quite big and strong
but maybe has conditioning issues
dominant when they're fresh but you
can't keep them on the court for more
than five minutes at a time
people would look at that person be like
okay well they they need to do
conditioning like the the way training
is fine they're already strong enough
they need to get in better shape so you
know I think people get that intuitively
but that same principle applies to
resistance training research where even
though at this point we do have a lot of
research suggesting that when you're
when you equate on a per set basis take
sets either to failure or pretty close
to failure on average moderate rep and
high rep sets result in the same
hypertrophy that doesn't necessarily
apply to all individuals and uh I think
that that applies in terms of both
content creators and content consumers
so uh for for Content creators if you
look at research and two things look to
be the same on average it's kind of easy
to put the message out there like oh
these two things are the same there's no
difference like everyone in my audience
either one totally valid option for you
it doesn't matter what you do
um and I think for for individual
consumers as well there's also kind of
uh
an urge to interpret things that way so
even if uh Someone putting out content
isn't being That explicit about it like
oh there's there's absolutely no
difference between these things you know
averages individuals they're the exact
same thing you kind of want to interpret
things that way so I I see this uh play
out for example like in discussions
about failure versus non-failure
training where you know uh you can look
at the research it seems like ah on
average there's not much of a difference
uh as long as the non-failure training
isn't just super super easy
um but then you know folks will get all
up in arms and be like hey I used to
train to failure all the time I I had
bad gains now I'm doing more like sub
maximal training my gains are a lot
better you know [ __ ] the science it's
all wrong
Yeah so basically you ask me a question
I give a fairly standard consensus
answer
and you purport to dunk on it but I know
you and I assume that you have some
evidentiary basis for this and
potentially even a specific study that
you'd like to discuss I do in fact have
one so
um you know this isn't the only study
that that illustrates the point I'm
trying to make but it's a study that was
published earlier this year so pretty
recent that does illustrate this point
quite well that just because two things
work similarly well on average that
doesn't necessarily mean they'll work
similarly well for all individuals so
the study I'm going to talk about is by
carniero and colleagues the title is
different load intensity transition
schemes to avoid plateau and no response
and lean body mass gain in
post-menopausal women so that's that's a
bit of a mouthful and we're actually not
going to talk much about the actual
topic of the study who knows might do
that next episode uh because I I think
that there's a lot of confusion about
High versus low responders
non-responders as well so that that
might be a good segment for the future
but right now we're talking about just
inter-individual responses to uh on
average similarly efficacious training
interventions
so in this study uh 24 healthy
post-menopausal women uh trained for 24
weeks completed a 24-week intervention
so they were randomly assigned to groups
and one of the groups completed 12 weeks
of low load training followed by 12
weeks of moderate load training so
crossover design and then the other
group completed 12 weeks of moderate
load training followed by 12 weeks of
low load training so both groups
completed the same 12-week block of
moderate load training and the same
12-week block of low load training just
in different orders
um the training consisted of three sets
of leg press knee extensions leg curls
and calf raises to failure or close to
failure three times per week the
moderate load group did sets of 8 to 12
Reps for all of those exercises every
training session or the the moderate
load condition the low load condition
involved doing sets of one of the more
random rep ranges I've heard of in the
literature sets of 27 to 31 reps I
disagree I always ask my clients have
you have you been doing your 27s like I
told you uh I don't think that's common
but more power to you and there was a a
progression mechanism in this study as
you would like to see so if a subject
completed more than 12 reps or more than
31 reps during their first set training
loads would be bumped up for their next
training session and this study assessed
lean soft tissue mass of the legs via
dexa pre-training mid training so at the
point where people were trained
transitioning between loading schemes
and post training and the group averages
were perfectly in line with the rest of
the research so in if you're watching on
YouTube we'll we'll Flash the graphic up
on the screen here but gains in lean
soft tissue mass of the legs which was
the proxy for hypertrophy in the study
were virtually identical with low load
and moderate load training on average
for both groups so you know not just
between groups but also within groups
they seem to be on average very very
similar
training stimuli to on average promote
gains in muscle muscle mass of the legs
however since this was a crossover study
that means we can also see how well
individuals responded to both low load
and moderate load training and again if
you're watching on YouTube will will
Flash the graphic up here
um so on average uh subjects gained
about three and a half four percent uh
lean soft tissue mass of the legs during
both of the 12-week training blocks but
the the individual responses were were
all over the place so uh kind of on the
most extreme end there was one person
who had a five percent decrease in lean
soft tissue mass of the legs following
moderate load training which is not good
that's not what you want to see and an
increase in excess of ten percent
following low load training so that
person did tremendously better with low
load training the moderate load training
and then just for another example
someone had like a 13 increase in lean
soft tissue mass of the legs following
moderate load training and like a three
percent increase following low low
training so they did tremendously better
with moderate low training
um so you know those are the sorts of
Within individual differences that can
be lurking beneath the surface
following two training interventions
that on average are similarly effective
um
so also if you're watching on YouTube
we'll throw up another visual here that
expresses the same information in a
slightly different way so it's a scatter
plot showing the relationship of how
much muscle someone gained during their
first 12 weeks of training versus how
much muscle they gained during their
second second 12 weeks of training with
the different training protocol and so
if the two training protocols were
equally effective for all individuals
what you would expect to see is just a
set of points that fell along the line
that could be expressed as x equals y so
just a straight diagonal line passing
through the origin going up into the
right with the points being pretty
clustered around that line and a strong
positive association between how well
you did with one training protocol and
how well you did with the other training
protocol
uh what we see is that there's basically
no correlation and if a correlation
exists it's a weak negative correlation
where uh you know essentially how well
you do on one how how well you did with
moderate load training didn't predict
how well you do with low load training
and vice versa and if anything and I I
want to read into this virtually any at
all but if anything doing really well
with moderate load training was slightly
negatively predictive of doing well with
low low training
um the beautiful thing about being the
video editor is I can cut that so that
it looks like it's the main point of the
entire talk when I when I do the Reel
when you say don't look don't read into
this too much I'm just going to clip
right after that just so you know oh God
okay that's fine whatever uh that's
that's the life I've signed up for I
guess
um
so yeah like those those were the
results so similarly effective on
average
massively differing responses within
individual and
um when I was on uh Dave Tate's table
talk uh a couple months ago this was a
point I brought up where I think that
there is maybe too much emphasis on
trying to figure out what on average
works well and not quite as much
emphasis on what works well for
individuals and how to predict what will
work well for individuals like I think
uh like study design should kind of move
in that direction and really there there
are two types of study designs where you
can get it information like this like
not just what works best on average but
like what what is the sort of
intra-individual variability in terms of
responses to different training
protocols and for that you either need
crossover studies like this one or you
need within subject unilateral designs
and I am seeing more within subject
unilateral designs crossover studies are
are still relatively rare and for good
reason
um you know this study if it was just a
parallel groups design it would be 12
weeks in and out per subject as it was
it was 24 weeks in and out per subject
um which you know if you're trying to
run a typical study with college kids
makes it very difficult to do that study
because most of the time people aren't
on campus for six months straight
they're generally going home for
Christmas and summer uh but anyway a
very good study design for looking in to
this type of question
um so I think that the that the main
takeaway here is this is an important
principle that that you should keep in
mind if you're a Content producer when
you're producing content and when you're
a Content consumer you should keep this
in mind when you're consuming content so
uh if you're someone who's producing
content you you need to be pretty
careful about generalizing your n equals
one experience to other people so you
know in this case uh one of these people
like let's say it's a post-menopausal
woman with a YouTube fitness channel and
she does moderate load training she does
her sets of eight to twelve she has a
five percent reduction in lean soft
tissue mass of the legs and says hey
look the fitness Industries [ __ ]
stupid they're saying do your sets of 10
for hypertrophy that's going to make you
lose muscle but if you do sets of 27 to
31 dude you're talking about an increase
in lean soft tissue mass of 10 percent
over three months like that's that's the
good [ __ ]
um and so you know that's a very common
issue I think where like even in kind of
the the evidence-based Community like
you'll you'll see where someone tries
something they get good results with it
and then instead of instead of just
saying like hey I tried this thing
here's my anecdote maybe give it a shot
they say well I observe this thing and
it had to have happened for a reason so
let's go into the literature and just
try to find maybe some mechanisms that
could potentially explain it to
therefore make my anecdote seem super
generalizable and scientific
um
so that's that's one thing to be aware
of uh and also just kind of the key
Point here is if you are starting with
kind of like a literature first approach
where you are are going into the
research looking to see what it says if
you're looking at two training
interventions that don't seem to have
differing effects on average that
doesn't mean that those two training
interventions won't have different
effects for a lot of individuals and
the the differences within in within
individual could potentially be quite
large
um
and if you're a consumer of information
I think it's important
to like when you read no difference uh
like two things on average seem to be
similarly effective
I I think that a lot of people have a
kind of positivity bias where they're
looking for things that work better than
other stuff so when they like when two
things are tested head to head and they
seem to be similarly effective I think a
lot of people subtly interpret that as
neither of these things worked because
neither of them worked better but really
most of the time it just means either
can work and it's probably worth
experimenting with
um because once again like those two
things could uh like one of them could
be much better for you or much worse
um
and I also think it's important when
you're consuming information
to not immediately assume that a
scientific finding or a piece of content
something creates is wrong because it
conflicts with your personal experience
so if you are one of the subjects in
this study who you know uh had a had a
nine percent larger increase in lean
soft tissue mass of the legs following
moderate load training you know if if
you've done that already that's your
experience and then research on moderate
load versus low load training starts
coming out and all of the science is
saying hey it doesn't seem like there's
much of a difference between these two
things on average
you can look at your experience and be
like no that's [ __ ] [ __ ] like
I've done both of these things one of
them clearly works much better
well it works much better for you like
that like just because of finding which
is looking at mean differences conflicts
with your personal experience that
doesn't mean that the finding is wrong
that could just mean that you had an
atypical response
um like that's
that's very common and I think that
people uh underestimate how how often
that occurs and I kind of think that the
the whole notion of conflating average
responses with individual responses I
think that there's a bit of a like an
ideological current underpinning it
where like this is probably a very
outdated reference now like I I don't
think I don't think this film has as
much cultural resonance with the kids
anymore but for people our age and
slightly older the film Fight Club and
Tyler durden's speech you are not a
special snowflake like I think that that
either was ideologically clarifying for
a lot of people or uh like you know
taking something they already believed
or suspected and kind of like putting a
catchphrase to it or it was like
influential for people who like didn't
have uh like under underlying
assumptions about the similarities or
differences between people already where
you know that like that idea kind of
sticks in your head of like no like
you're not a special snowflake I'm not a
special snowflake you know people uh
share like 99.9 of their genes there's
there's no way that you're that
different from anyone else so if we find
something that is generally effective
from a training perspective nutrition
perspective whatever
um if it works pretty well for most
people It's gotta work for you too and
if it's not it's just because you're
[ __ ] lazy and not trying hard enough
um like I I think that that's
like
it
it's more it's more wrong than right but
I think that that's just kind of like a
tacit underlying assumption and
heuristic that a pretty large group of
people just go through the world with
um
and
yeah like there there are a lot of
instances where things that work well
for you may not work that well for other
people and vice versa like things that
don't seem to be generally efficacious
or not more efficacious than some
alternative on average could be really
really good for you
um and and I think that it that's always
worth keeping in mind like when we're
dealing with scientific research that is
examining mean differences group
averages
um you know your personal experiences
will probably comport with the average
experience a pretty good chunk of the
time but you shouldn't expect it to
comport with average responses all of
the time or maybe even most of the time
um so that's just uh yeah that's that's
really the point I'm trying to make and
and I thought that this study was uh a
pretty good just kind of like case study
to to illustrate this point so Eric are
there any weird little things that may
not be just a generally great advice
from a training or nutrition perspective
that you found to work really well for
you personally
yeah I mean the one thing that comes to
mind for me is uh
starting out when I first got into
lifting I became very fond of the what
would be called the Bro split uh low
frequency per muscle group but very high
volume per session for each muscle group
so you go in and just beat this [ __ ] out
of your pecs for like 90 minutes right
and you won't touch them again for seven
days yeah and you know then I got into
the whole science thing and I started
looking at the research and saying okay
well but but what is what it ought to be
the optimal way to do it right you start
putting together these heuristics and
these guidelines of frequency okay at
least two or three times a week and
volume per session we want to look at
some of these thresholds at which at
which point something kind of gets more
into like junk volume versus like really
high quality volume and stuff like that
and you know all throughout the years
I've experimented with different
approaches and
I I wouldn't say that you know the the
kind of more evidence-based approach
Works poorly for me but I will say I
made progress on low frequency training
programs that had very high volume per
session I made really great gains on bro
splits that just don't seem compatible
with kind of best practice guidelines or
even some of the literature uh
suggesting that they are less favorable
that would be the one thing that that
comes to mind for me what about you so
for for me uh my my one weird trick that
helped my squats more than almost
anything else was breathing pause squats
and so if if you're if you're an old
school Greg Head uh you probably know
about these I don't think I've talked
about them publicly since maybe like
2015 2016 or so
um but yeah like so my my squats are are
at this point and have been for a long
time my best lift and getting really
good at squats uh was kind of a two-step
process where I I did two things that
may not be generally advisable first I
did kind of like Bulgarian style
training like daily Maxes I'm squatting
multiple times per day working up to a
Max doing back off volume just way more
than should theoretically be ideal
worked really well for me and then when
that stopped working as well I just like
I don't even remember how I came up with
this but I still never felt like really
comfortable at the bottom of a squat and
I felt like I couldn't brace well so I
came up with breathing pause squats
which like I'm sure someone else did
previously but I just hadn't come across
anecdotes of it before where essentially
I'd get a pretty light load go down and
just like pause for a long time and by a
long time I'm not talking like a five
count I'm talking like a minute or two
so you know I'd be doing full deep
inhales exhales but like still bracing
but not trying to be like over like
exclusively reliant on intra-abdominal
pressure to brace and like kind of hold
myself there
um
and boy like that that was probably
second only to the Bulgarian style stuff
the most effective thing I ever did for
my squat
um and I I fell into the Trap of
assuming that since they were so
effective for me they had to they had to
be good for other people too
um and so I I kind of put that out into
the world and like this this isn't
scientific like I haven't you know uh
recruited 200 people and told all of
them to do it and collected all of their
responses but just in terms of kind of
anecdotes I've heard back from people
who who gave breathing Paul squats a
shot it seems that for probably about 80
percent of people like they don't do
anything
um like they're they're not bad they're
just not uh any more productive than any
other squat auxiliary lift you could do
but for like 10 20 of people they are
like borderline magical where you know
over the span of three four months they
put like
70 pounds on someone's squat so you know
that's like I think a good example of a
an approach to training or in this case
like an exercise that really for the for
the vast majority of people it's not
generally efficacious but if if it turns
out to be the thing that you need it
like nothing else seems to scratch the
same itch yeah yeah yeah I do think that
you know this is an important overall
point uh to kind of keep an eye out for
these individual level differences I
mean like I said
I've had great responses personally to
programs that don't seem to be optimal
based on you know the the meta-analytic
research so I I still if I'm working
with a brand new client I have no idea
about their training history or they
don't really feel confident in saying
they respond better to this or that you
start with what seems to work best for
most people and then you individualize
from there you know and I am excited
about you know there are all these areas
of the research where we say uh well we
need more research here but who knows
when we're going to get it right I
actually very firmly believe that we
will get a lot more clarity about
inter-individual differences within the
next five to ten years in specifically
exercise and sport nutrition I I think
we are on the cusp I know specific
individuals who are working toward like
how do we really effectively quantify
this and model it and make better
inference is about it yeah and that ball
has been rolling very slowly and people
have in some cases jumped the gun and
said like oh I've got the perfect way to
do this then you look back and you say
I think you're you're modeling
measurement error not individual
responses right yeah but I do believe
five or ten years from now we're gonna
be able to get much a much better grasp
on how you know to what extent different
individuals truly differ with these
different outcomes uh Beyond just hey
sometimes equipment has measurement
error you know yeah yeah so I think that
it's I think that'll it'll be a two-step
process where one
we need to be able to quantify the
between and within individual
differences but then two kind of where
where all of this hopefully is going is
trying to find useful predictors so you
know like it it's all well and good to
say as we can right now ah yeah moderate
and low low training on average seem to
produce similar responses you can look
at individual data and it seems some
people do considerably better with one
or the other the next step is then to
say okay but can we predict which one
you'll do best with right
um
and yeah like I I hope that's where
things are going
I agree